so for everyone I've been talking to
recently I've been playing something
called get to know your cast member or
whatever I swear these are harmless
questions and we'll see what you guys
think what TV show would you love to
guest star on wait for the other person
oh no for you Oh mm-hmm um I was like
trying to think I'm like West world it's
always sunny okay
do you have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy
film that's so hard I mean I love Lord
of the Rings attic watch it once a year
extended cuts are the normal guts
normal cuts okay I'm gonna not to
interject you try the extended cuts next
time they're a fresh tank the first
movie is infinitely better as an
expansion there's like some very key
scenes that you will be like are you
kidding me how is this not in the movie
cool I would say Todd it's hard because
that's like my favorite I have to go
back to ET or 2001 sure what film scared
you as a kid
it oh the tree yeah yeah yeah it scared
me as a kid I mean I remember the first
time I just shot the shining but I was
not a kid kid um I honestly I don't
remember I'm sorry that's cool Exorcist
I watched that far too young a lot of
people say that yeah I watched that far
too young but it was great
sure is there anything that you collect
books it's much better than my I collect
whiskey right both of these are good
answers do you own any movie or TV show
props oh yeah no you didn't borrow
anything from the set on this one I have
something yeah you have you have
something pretty great from from this
movie coming your way what I was gonna
wait and tell them the premiere but
you'll see yeah big day I have a lot of
stuff from lost really is obsessed with
that show and can you share one of the
things you have um Damon gave me just so
much stuff from that show because he
knew I was just obsessed with it so he
gave me one of the the polar bear
biscuits some of the Dharma beer mr.
clucks chicken one of those virgin
mary's statues with heroin in it yes
yeah
not actual heroin but I I understand
yeah I am also a huge fan of that show
yeah I will just start and interject but
I'm curious I love the finale the series
finale I'm honestly I've and I'm not
embarrassed to say I've seen this show
three times the whole way through yes
so you love the finale I I will never
give up on lost I love it all okay no no
I do I actually I you know I to be
honest I call I called it I knew it
oh so oh yeah you're you were like and I
show up from way you know at the
beginning of the show um I go there I'm
very curious if you can call the end of
Game of Thrones
have you figured it out no I don't know
are you watching it I'm not up to date
so she's right I read like ever after
every I don't I haven't read the books
and I actually don't want to because I
just feel but I do read all the online
forums after so I know you sort of yeah
I love it right it's my favorite show on
TV right now do you have a prediction on
how it ends
no but I mean I really I really am
McAleese I listen I like Jon Snow he's
cool he's not like my hero like I'm kind
of like more I'm all about the Hound
like you know what I mean like so I'm
hoping that they all end up okay but
like I'm not as concerned with Jon Snow
is everyone else's which it's a very
unpopular opinion no I love that you're
a geek about it and also that Lord of
the Rings it's also something I'm
surprised but I think Game of Thrones
the what they're doing is spectacularly
at it and if they and if they stick the
landing it might be on par with some
other show called Breaking Bad you know
what I mean I heard that shows good too
yeah it is very good yeah that shows
definite landing you know what I mean
what's the background photo on your
phone um it used to be a picture of me
and my husband and then I was like this
seems like a great way to get my phone
so on so um oh look at that
no it's like peonies this is my baby
notifications but it's flowers that my
husband got me oh our new coffee table
oh I was gonna say you've answered this
question but what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once oh man
more than once I don't think that I have
ever done that good it's hard to go back
again
I've definitely like oh you're saying
it's hard to go back mmm we have to go
back I've definitely watched I like that
I've watched a good amount of like
episodes of Game of Thrones multiple
times but I remember me watched the
whole thing you know I think I'm gonna
do it when the show finally ends yeah
yeah are you excited about the spin-off
yes yes yeah just cos Jane Goldman's
involved
she's a great writer and if you're not
familiar with her work she's an
excellent writer and you know let's hope
for the best
yeah um for each of you do you remember
what got you involved or made you want
to be part of the entertainment industry
yeah I was living in London my mom was
teaching there and so she had really
cheap theater tickets and I was like
four and we would go to the theater all
the time like three times a week and I
was I'm an only child so I was like
obsessed with it and would put on
performances for my parents on the
nights that we weren't going and that's
how when I got came back to the u.s. I
signed up for theater school and that
was that love it yeah I mean I've just
been obsessed with I think performing
from a very young age but when I saw
movies like Stand By Me Goonies I saw
kids just doing it on such a different
level and that's when I kind of started
saving up my change you know to make
them move to LA thank you both so much
and Congrats on the movie and thank you
for answering the fun stupid questions
yeah
you